>>M BORIS SA
>> I AM CHI PAUL.
WE GU THBUE KIAN OPENED FIRE.
SUPERMARRGODN  GUY G
ARMY STYLE.
WAS WEOR MILITA-S HE ALS ST PEYN
PULLED UP YESTERY
IE AND BEGAN OOTING.
SPOIFICALFOR ITDEMOGRAPHICSACL
AREA THAT HAD A
. E  HEAVILYRM
TACTICAL GEAR.
HE A OTR AT HE WAS DO>> THEPE IE
D
CHRGES A T.
L AGENES NOW
E VIIATE C  NG AS A
HIRC A TO, REPORTEDLY WRITE
FROM BUFFALO R US
?ATE
BASICALLY UR THAMANI MENTIONED.T
OW AS THIS
ITWI
LOSS ONITY MEMBERSOW
E OCERY
STTHNING WL LIKELY R SOMEIME,S
AUTHORITIES VERY QUICKLY
ANNOUNCEEY WILL BE HANDLING
THIS LEAST AT THE FERAL
LEL,LYOTIVATED
- VIOLENT STREEPISM.ACT, JUSW H
PULLED U
S  G OIS VEHLLEO SAY THAT HE WA
13 SHOT,THE VICTIM B
IN TERMSFR, T A HODRIV TO HEAR
HANDLED
POINT.
>> THIS URIT WASGHT-UPED HATE C
SIDE OF THE CITY
OF GOOD  THEMM TFL
ON THASUY ARRST-DEGREE MURDER YA
FEDERAL COMPINVESTATKELYTH MORCE
BUT THERE ARE -- THERE IS DEE T
BEEN POSTED ONLINE JUST DAYS HO
TO LRNE
THFAMILIES A
HAT TRIED TO
FACT,CTUAL
ECY,NEATTENTION ON TT  A KILLED
L
LETITIA S YE
AMONG MANY THINGS THEY WILL BE
SPENAYING ARE SOCIAL THE ONEO P,
TOLENCEPRECIATE ALLILSOTOOK
O N WHITE HOUSE
JASMINE, ALWAYS GOOD TO SE
I BEEN
IC STER HE WAS BRIEFED WELL, PR
ON SATURDAY.
MAKING FH D LAIG TO BE TIONS FOH
ANE LEAR -
TO READ YOU TH-- HE SAID
CICRIME
E VERY FABRIC Y ACT OFF A WHITE
ONID IT I
AL AND IN E STATEN
RELE HE ALSO ANKED FIRST RESPOND
OTHER LAW OFFICIAL -LAEN
ECTEND THE NIO
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER MEMORIAL, HL
GIVE REMARKS. THAT AS
CHRISTI?IO
BORIS?
>>TREL
PRINLARE MUC
HT NALYSIS NOWITHNNONAL SECURIT
JULIETTE KAYYEM.
WA G
YOFOR THESE
CEOBTAINED
THS ALF IT LIFTED FROM TCORNERS.
R DESCRIBILF
INHIN ANTI-SEMITE,OSACY THEORY
COUNTRY.
IT IRY SIMILRIORISTS
HAVEEERETRIKESE AS A
COPYCAT-TYPE AA IRENT?
>> IT IS.K EXPOSES -- I THI T
TND
TO THINK A OF  LONLFAN WE LEARN
TISSUE, CONNECTING THESE CNECTED
ANWE SAW ON SATURDAY.
THSTO,--T RAMBLING'THIPEOPLE ASG
UBHAT WE TSPE.R,
OF -OF RACANTTERS BECAUSREPLACE
WE AMERICAN ID.HE O IIS CASE,
M THREATENS  ABILITY, AS THWH TE
D S .TO EXIST IN AMERICA.
T RACISM BECAU IT IS
O RID YOURSELF OE .
ANIS IS TH TTI LEADING
ISM.CA
ITHEORY  PROTEEXTREMIS
>> AND THAF THIN IS
ECHOED OFTENEVY SOSTOSN -- O
CABLE >> YEAH. NDILAR T
MOSQUE IN NEZERCH INA.
TH H
SEEMS TONOWLEDHAAS
RADILIARE SOME PEOPLMO SPT
TO THIS SO
OTRS
THE BELIEFS THEY HAVE, OR THE BK
L T ATION IS IWE LIKSOE TO US OR
U E INUNDATE
AT L WHYOTOFEO SEE
IN, THOUGH.
SO, WHY ITNEI HATEO SA
SUPRY,N TES RED IN
LEADERS, RIGHTTHCA MEDIA
ESPOUSING THE SAME
THEY ARE DOINGT INIS RELATIVELY.
PLAUSIBLE
DENIABILY.
HIS GUY.
THN'T TELL HIM IT.
WRO YESTEAY, .IS
HENOHED.AND WHARTICUY, HIM?
WE W OUT OVER TIME BUT
THAT IS BASICALLY HOW